ne
[Müzik]
duyduysan
Ee bugün
karar bilimi ve davranış bilimleri
dediğimiz iki disiplin ekseninde bir şey
anlatacağım Sizi asla insani bilimler
çatısı altında bir insani bilimler
gerçekten
olguları Olayları nesneleri kişileri
kullanarak bizi muhteşem çıkarımlar
yapma şansı tanır Ben de o çıkarım
lardan birini yapacağım
kriptopara lardan bahsedeceğim Ama tabii
ki derdim Kripto paranın işte grafikleri
İnan çıkan yükselen gelecekte ne olur
falan gibi yatırım kısmıyla değil Çok az
konuşulan kısmı ile ilgili birşeyler
söylemeye çalışacağım yani Kripto
paralarına arkasındaki davranış
bilimlerini size Anlatmaya çalışacağım
Davranış Bilimleri önemlidir bu o da
karar bilimi Bunlar bizim kesişim
alanında Mesela örnek diye söyleyeceğim
seni biraz sunumdan önce açayım o kısmı
bize ne anlatır Davranış Bilimleri deli
vardır toplumsal sine bilimin en önemli
isimlerinden biri bi geçen yıllarda
yaptığı bir araştırmasındaki böyle geniş
bir spektrumda yapılan bir araştırma
uzun zamanda sürüyor şöyle bir çıkarım
yapıyor hosted tıraş ol yani düz kişi
diye bir kavram ortaya koyuyor
ve dürüstlük işi kavramına göre eğer
sevgiliniz ya da eşiniz sahte çanta
kullanıyorsa ya da Torrent den yada ip
TV den falan üye olmadan yani haksızlık
sınırında bir film izleme operasyonuna
giriyorsa dilin ki onun sizi aldatma
ihtimali bunu yapmayan daha fazladır
o Çünkü dürüstlük eşi birleşiktir Çok
basit O işin ya altında sındır
geliştirilmesidir başka bir ihtimal yok
tüm mesele Hani şeydir ya hepinize
sorsam rüşvet alır mısınız ya da İhaleye
fesat karıştırma mısınız diye sorsam şey
diyeceksiniz Hayır asla yapmam sonra
hepimiz yapmaya sonra mesela bugüne
kadar da yapmadık da diyebilirsiniz
belki bir takım imkanların izi geçmiştir
orada belki gerekli rakam teklif
edilmemiştir Dolayısıyla dürüstüm böyle
küçüğü büyüğü diye bir kavram yok mesela
ya da on yaşında bir kızım var elimin
biz böyle doğanın çok içerisinde bir
yerde yaşıyoruz böyle spiral orman bir
bölge giriyorsun içeri Biz karda
kaybolduk O yüzden zaten gelişim zor
öyle ifade ettim elinin doğayı sevmesi
lazım herkesten daha fazla sevmesi lazım
orada Onu tam içerisinde şu etrafta
insan yok hiçbir şey yok gibi bir
destinasyonun Tıka düşünün fakat
50.000 oldukça takdiri si yüksek bu
Görünürlüğü çok seven ve buna çok büyük
anlamlar atfeden Bir kız çocuğuydu iki
yaşından beri aşı kartları vardır onları
Hani çocuk doktorları tekerleri Aferin
işte Merhaba Süpersin evin falan onları
küçük kutusunda saklayan bir kızdan
bahsediyoruz ve doğa ile ilgilenmeye çok
kirli buluyor değil mi bir türlü ne
yaptıysam onu doğaya yakınlaştırma
Mıştım basit bir hile olabilir pedagojik
olarak çok problemli şöyle bir şey
yaptım gittim Bir Fidancı dan 150 tane
Ihlamur fidanı aldım biliyorsunuz çok
güzel kokar Bizim oturduğumuz bölgesi
vasfını yitirmiş bir bölgede evine dedim
ki elin Bunlar ıhlamur ağacı bunlar
harika kokarlar seninle birlikte bu
ağaçlardan dikeceğiz Bunlarında elimin
ağacı olsun 20 yıl sonra her yer Elvin
kokacak dedim ve Elvin benimle birlikte
bir buçuk ay ağaç dikti davranışın
arkasındaki motivasyonu bulmak esas
olandır şimdi o yüzden Kripto paraları
konuşurken önemli şeyler konuşacağız
bizimle ilgili çok fazla şey yapma
fırsatını bulacağız zaten bu konuşmayı
yapmaya karar vermem esnasında bir
istatistik beni dürtük dedi
Aslında Kripto paralar son 5 yıldır 10
yıldır değil ama son 5 yıldır değil mi
dünyamızın önemli parçası elinde
grafikte dolaşanlar cep telefonuna bakıp
indi çıktı diyenler hayatı kendine kahve
edenler durduk yere sevilenler uçağın
yani masada bir anda birisini sıçradı
gülüyorsun yahu Ne oldu falan diye
korktum da adam atmamışsın ki işte
yatırım yaptı kriptokoin tam o dakika
itibariyle yüzde yirmi yedi artmış falan
var ya böyle acayip bir howlite var
sadece bu da değil 3 trilyon dolara
yaklaşan bir hacimden söz ediyoruz dünya
çapında Türkiye 8 milyar dolarlık bir
ekonomi olduğunu düşünürseniz Yaklaşık
dört katı Bitcoin zaten uzun yıllardır
bütün yatırım dünyasında ilk onda yeter
mi konu zorluyor bu kadar büyük bir
hacim fakat bilgilendim istatistik bu
değildi bir başka istatistik O da çok
önemli Amerika'nın büyük yatırım
bankalarından biri wells Fargo
bu geçtiğimiz yıl yaptığı araştırmada
Kripto paradan zengin olma umudunun
artık 15 yaşına kadar indiğini ve
çocukların harç paralarını okul
paralarını yurt paralarını Kripto para
yatırdığını ortaya koymuştu bayağı sakil
bir durumlardan baksanız fakat peşinde
koştum isteslik Bu da değildi bir başka
isteslik sihirli Senin böyle geniş
kapsamlı çalışmasından geliyor yere
jenerasyonu Milyonerler dediğimiz
Amerika'daki Milyonerler kulübü ne
baktığımızda bu milyonerlerin yani genç
Milyonerler Bunlar yüzde seksen içinde
kriptopara portreyi var yüzde seksen
3'ün yüzde 53'ü de aslında kriptopara
yardımıyla milyonerlik sıfatını erişmiş
ve bu insanların 100'de 95'i kriptopara
yatırımı yapmaya devam edeceğini
söylüyor Fakat benim peşinde koştum ise
sık bulabildi benim peşinde koştum
istatistik bu meşhur dünya ekonomik
forumu'nun 2007/21 Kapanı ne söylediği
bir rakam vardı o çok ilgimi çekti size
ilginizi çekecek dünyada nüfusa oranla
en fazla Kripto para yatırma yapan
ülkelere baktığımızda bir numarada
Nijerya var Aklıma boku arama getiriyor
iki numarada Vietnam var hiç bitmeyen
savaş sonrası travmalar 3 numara da
Filipinler var Zaten iki günde bir darbe
oluyor ya girişimi oluyor dünyada en çok
kriptopara Sakine sahip ülke bu peki
sürpriz olmazsa dördüncüsü kim
ama
biz dünya dördüncüsü yüz Avrupa
birincisiyiz bu Felaket bir şey de
olabilir ya da söyle değerlendirmeye
dünyada teknoloji yeni algılayan
teknoloji yeni tekrar olan ve geleceği
teknoloji üzerinden kurgulayan üç
ülkenin bu üç ülke olduğunu düşünüyorsak
bekliyorum Hiç bana öyle gelmiyor size
böyle gelmedim ortada çok ciddi mesela
var soru şu Biz niye oradayız
basit cevaplar verilebilir işte
enflasyon rakamı yüksek işte Bol etli
ortamlar para değerini kaybediyor falan
yok bundan anlatılamaz bunu Davranış
Bilimleri kurmak lazım bakın konuştuğum
konu şu an Kripto paralarına kendisi
değil kriptopara borsasından
bahsediyoruz Biz zaten 49 da pek
konuşmuyoruz Kripto paranın gelecekte
Tabii ki yeri var zaten şu anda gelecek
oluşmaya başladı her bir sorunun çözümü
Kimisi sadece Turizm parası kimi sadece
start-up parası Kimisi güvenlik
duvarları oluşturarak müthiş biraz
zincir oluşturuyor Kimisi Merkezi o
nedeniyle paranın akışkanlığını takip
edilmek çok zor zaten biliyorsunuz
birçok
blackstreet operasyonunda yani o kara
para ticaretinde kullanıldığını
biliyoruz işte rusya-ukrayna savaşından
sonra olursa ambargoları acaba Kripto
parayla deler mi gibi bir tartışma söz
konusu kıpır alın kendisi işleri Sen
asıl mesele Kripto paraların Neden bizim
tarafımızdan Hele ki bizim ülkemiz
tarafından bu kadar çok ilgi gördü bunun
için üç buçuk aylık bir çalışma
yürüttüğüm toplam 367 kişiyle görüştüm
Araştırmanın sonuçlarını size 16 madde
halinde sıralayacağım
367 kişinin 100 de 50 3'ünde kriptopara
yatırımı vardı en az bir kere ticaretini
yapmışlar bu insanların yaş ortalaması
32 ve bu insanların yüzde 85'i erkek ve
bu insanların yüzde 44 edip toplamda
Kripto paradan kazanan insanlardı Onlara
sordum hem projektif teknik anketler
aracılığıyla dedi nefes ile görüşmelerde
makale yiyeceğim buradayız çıktılarını
anlatıyorum ve 16 tane madde Ortaya
koydum bu 16 madde sıralamaya başlıyorum
bir diyorum arkadaşlar
ekranda göreceksiniz diye tahmin
ediyorum Evet Bitcoin hücumu zengin
olmamı dedim 1848 yılının size
hatırlatayım Western filmlerinden çokça
denk gelmişsiniz dir zengin olma
umuduyla dört kıtada yolculuk yapan
insanlar elinde eleklerden tutun
Madencilik dikkatinizi çekiyor mu
bitcoin'de de Madencilik diyoruz
ve Madencilik aynı zengin olma umudunun
bir parçası olan sürü psikolojisinden
bahsediyoruz
1848'de 1960'a kadar sürdü insanlar dört
kıtaya dolaşarak yani meksi kadar yukarı
oregon Annem adaya Alaska'ya
daha nerelerde Yeni Zelanda Avustralya
Amerika'nın o altın ülke olması meselesi
o mineral üzerine kurma metaforu vardır
ya aslında bu sebeple aynısını mm yıllar
sonrasında yaşıyoruz yeni zenginlik
umuduyla insanlar ellerinde Bitcoin
Madencilik yapıyorlar bu sürü
psikolojisi Siz bunu bir kenara
koyuyorum birisi yaparsa ikincisi
yaparken Siz yaparsa herkes yapabilir ki
hayatınızda ne kadar Sürükleyici bir şey
olduğunu biliyorsunuz sürü
psikolojisinin Şimdi geliyorum iki
maddeye
yenilik dürtüsü ve ödülü arzusu var
bunun yüzünden kriptopara yatırım
yapıyoruz şimdi
Ya aslında
dünyaca ünlü bisiklet ırk ol incir
Robert kol ince bir ifade ile bir
terminoloji ile karşılık veriyor neofilo
video pek çoğumuz ne Filiz aslı nereden
bakarsanız bakın
yenilikle birlikte o hani zaten
Türkiye'nin o fil bir ülke bu arada işte
Akıllı telefonlar çok en çok bir satın
alıyoruz arabaların yeni modellerinde en
çok bir satın alırız Öyle edattır Sitesi
tüketici davranışlarında erken adaptif
insanlar kişi başına milli gelirimiz az
bile olsa biz çok açız Yenile Bu anlamda
sebebi dip toplamını Davranış Bilimleri
farklı olabilir Ama buna kesinlikle
açacağız n harfini Aslı evrimsel
biyoloji açısından bakıldığında da
nörokimyasal Lara biyolojik birimlerin
fiziksel olarak Timur bunları çok güzel
ifade etti Onun tamamlayıcısı gibi kabul
edin
insanın mutlu olma durumunu yükselten
serotonin ve dopamin ile birlikte
aslında bir sonraki maddiye de köprü
kurayım Yani kim bu içine kadar
gidebilecek bir İyi olma durumunu ifade
ediyor aslında ya fili İnsanlar yeni
şeyler yaparak kendi kimliklerini
kuruyorlar 3. maddede o kimlik temsili
şimdi önemli hepimiz kimlik kurmaya
çalışıyoruz hayattaki yolculuğumuz bu
benlikler üzerinden Hareket ediyoruz
hepimizin bireysel vermeyi var Kolektif
beğenmeyi var sembolik bir etkileşimli
Benli var bir de kendi içinde o bireysel
belli yaşadığımız açık benliğimiz gizli
benliğimiz örtük beğendiğiniz kör
benliğimiz var Bütün bu benliklerin
toplamı bizim Kimliğimizi oluşturuyor ve
Bitcoin ve benzeri Kripto paraları ya
yatırımı yapmak adeta kendini
gerçekleştiren Kehanet gibi ki o da
maddelerden biri yapmak zorundasın Yani
bugün 11 00 Nokia telefonu masanın
üzerine koysak herhalde herkesin aklına
sadece şu gelin maddi imkânsızlıklar
Dolayısıyla falan değil de adam herhalde
izlenmekten falan korkuyor takip ediyor
O yüzden bu telefonu kullanıyor falan
derler garip seri zaman bu kriptopara
yatırım yapmakta artık o kadar garip
silecek kimliğin Kabul etmeyecek bir
temsil bir diğeri gençlik ve Dijital
cihaz mi
sürekli bunu konuşuyoruz gençlik ve
Dijital cihaz be nedir
Genç olmak dijital Doğanlar Yeni
jenerasyon jenerasyonu bu insanlar
teknolojinin bir parçası adeta bir beden
uzantısı gibi sahibi olduğu gibi düşünün
cep telefonu bedenin uzantısı evde
durduğunda unuttuğunda hayatın o gün
için kitleniyor öyle düşün Bu dijital
Cazibe ile birleştiği zaman asla kimliği
güçlendiren ve özellikle gençliği
üzerinde bir etki yaratan Suphi zaten
dünya çapında kriptopara yatırımlarına
baktığımızda ağırlığın genç kitle de
olduğunu görüyoruz ki bizdeki kitle
benim Araştırmanızı yüzde 32'si çıktı
zaten
O 30 yaş homo bu hayatı bir şey yani
firovn misin Kağıt yani birşeyleri
kaçırma korkusu bunu Hayatın her
alanında yaşıyoruz Aslında her alanda
istisnasız marka tüketim kültürü
reklamlar
siyaset Kültür Sanat aile evlat evlenme
ve şehirli kadınların 35 yaşında
geçtiğinde çocuk sahibi olamaması
ihtimali nedeniyle bir an önce evlenme
zorlanması var ya metodolojisi tam
olarak bu filozof misin kağıttan
kaynakları biyolojinin artık izin
vermeyecek bir an önce evler o kadar çok
alanda yaşanıyor ki bu bunun kurbanı
olmamak Çünkü bu bir kurban psikolojisi
mümkün değil ve insanlar olası muhteşem
bir ihtimali kaçırmaktan o kadar çok
korkuyorlar ki O rakam o grafik nerede
olursa olsun trene sonradan binecek bile
olsa kriptopara yaptığımı yapıyor
mutlaka bu bir başka faktör Evet bir
başka faktör kendi bu gerçekleşti renk
alet Şimdi
ben timur'a sürekli şöyle desem Timur
Siz Arkadaşlarınızla birlikte bir kumpas
kurduğunu ve beni akıl hastanesine
kapatmaya çalışıyorsunuz bu zaten yanlış
bir sanrı ve ruh sağlığı açısından
sorunlu marazi bir davranış olduğu için
bir zaman sonra zaten benim sağlıksız
olduğunu ortada bir akıl hastanesine
kapatmak zorunda kalırlar ya da
sevgilisini çok kıskanan bir insanın
Sürekli onun üzerinde baskı oluşturması
sürekli gittiği yerleri takip etmesi
aklınıza ne geliyorsa bunu yaptığım bir
zaman sonra bu baskıya dönemeyen sevgili
elinde sonra terk edecektir onu İşte
buna Biz kendini gerçekleştiren Kehanet
temiz Kripto paralar da böyle çalışıyor
1 milyon dolar olacak Çok az olacak
dünya gelecekte böyle çok zengin
olacaksınız gelecekte sadece kriptopara
olacak yükselecek yükselecek derken
herkes oturuyor Dino ticaretin bir
parçası haline geliyor mecbur olarak bir
başkası
futf irans Orti ve dart yani korku bu
belirsizlik ve şüphe ve o kadar
dezenformatif manipülatif ve Spekülatif
piyasa ortamını görüyorsun ki sürekli
olarak arkadan bir şey istiyor bakın
borsa gibi Manipülasyon ağlarında
olabilir borsada Manipülasyon bizim
kabul etmediğimiz bir yatırımlarını
spekülasyon olabilir Manipülasyon olamaz
bunun izni görüyoruz bazen ilgili
örgütler yatırım kuruluşları İşte bu
kriptoda ki Balinalar aracılığıyla falan
bu hareketin yaratılması lazım yukarı
çıkartılır aşağı indirir 1 milyon doları
Beklerken bir anda 35 bin dolara Yener
bu hareketi olmadığında biz buna
Bonfilet ediyoruz ilmeğe çıkma gibi
düşünün Bunu zaten o piyasanın etkin bir
piyasa olma ihtimali sıfır olacak
borsada var Fakat bu Trident Mini yani
ticaretin tümünü artıran bir faktör
Hacım artıran faktör Dolayısıyla korku
belirsizlik ve şüphe kesinlikle bir
davranış Bilmem motivasyonu Evet bir
başka madde kumar oynamayacağını şimdi
buraya itiraz edenler olabilir ama Etkin
piyasa teorisinde kum bu arasındaki fark
arkasının takip edilebilir olmasıdır
değil mi borsa yatırımı yaparken
bilançoları okursun karlılığa Bakarsın
yeni yatırımlarına bakarsın falan filan
Şimdi Kripto paralarına Neye bakacaksın
basit bir beklediği ileride çok iyi
olacakmış olur ya da olmaz bilmiyorum
yani Ama olacakmış
Dolayısıyla kumar oynama tutkusunun
yatırım davranışı ile birleşti böyle
Bıçak Sırtı bir yerde yer alıyor fakat
kumar dediğiniz bağımlılık bugün
davranışsal ki 2019'da Dünya Sağlık
Örgütü davranışsal bağımlılığı
bağımlılık kısmını da anlatacağım bu
aynı zamanda bir bağımlılık maddesel
bağımlılıkların çok daha üstünde koydu
daha kitlesel daha ulaşılabilir
sayesinde ulaşılabiliyor Sun bir
Sürdürülebilir gibi görünüyor o yüzden
Kripto çok net olarak bir kumar
davranışına döndü pek çok durum söz
konusu yani 10 bin tane Kripto paraları
her birinin ismi bölüm varsa Filiz'e
gönderecek O akıllı araçların ismi gibi
kim onun grafiğine bakıyor arkasındaki
fikir ne falan herhalde 3D Birlik bir
rakam olsa oldukça iyi bir sonuç
çıkacaktır ki benim araştırmam da yüzde
on birlik rakam Kripto paranın
arkasındaki gerçek proje yani borsa
değil toparın kendi polisim bildiğini
söyledi ki oldukça düşük rakam batık
maliyeti yanılgısı Türkiye'de ve dünyada
evliliklerin çoğu nedeni bu
var ya evlenmişsin 22 yıldır evlisin
Aslında berbat gidiyor mantıksal ve
rasyonel olarak Buna devam etmen
gerekiyor yatın Hiç
çürüyorsun öyle olduğunu düşünüyorsun
evlisin defa fazla maliyet koymuşsun
çocuklarınız olmuş iş ortaklığı sülale
ortaklığı Hatta suç ortaklığı Ne
dersiniz diyeyim bundan Vazgeçmek çok
zor kriptopara da böyle yatırma
yapıyorsun sürekli olarak İnan çıkar
yerlerde bazen kazanıyorsun bazen
kaybediyorsun ama ben bir şey söyleyeyim
mi Aslında hep kaybediyoruz Şimdi bunu
şey gibi düşün yatırım davranışına bir
sonraki maddede Bunu size ifade edeceğim
İntikam ticareti bir başka Davranış
Bilimleri motivasyonu Kripto parayı
aldın 35 bin dolardan çıktı 65 bin
dolara sonra indi 49 bin dolara kazandın
mı kaybettin mi ve mobilyalara kazandın
35 TL aldım 45 den satın 10.000 dolar
kazanacağım var fakat gittiği yer 65w
Orada satmadı Aynen şu doların işte
18'ler vurup düştüğünde herkesin
kaybettiği düşünmesine rağmen adam 626
dan almış kazandın Ama bir kere gördüğü
tipi Dolayısıyla bu yatırımda kaybederiz
Çünkü her yatırım bir noktadan sonrası
Nihal noktası tekrar başlar 65 bin dolar
değilse artık onu fiyatı Zinde kapatmış
15 bin dolardır Bu da intikam ticaretini
yol açar bir de alırsın bir daha alırsın
bir da alırız gerçekten dürtüsel ve
dürtüsüyle hareket
bir başka madde bağımlılık
da zaten bunun Hani aşikar bunu
yorumlamaya bile gerek yok ama Kripto
paranın içine girdiğin zaman kolay kolay
ter gidemeyeceğim bir bağımlılık türü
olduğu önemli bir davranışsal
bağımlılıklar oldu ortada zaten ne kadar
kaybetse de şartları elverdiği sürece
İlk parayı sarmayı bulduğu zaman klip ve
getirilerinin tekrar tekrar alma devam
ettiğini görüyorsun işin içerisinde ödül
var ceza var kazanmak var kaybetmek var
aslında seni nörokimyasal olarak
çekecekler içinde barındıracak her şey
bunu da var biraz aşık gibi sevgi var
nefret var Ne arasam çok yüksek Duygu
beyni Noel enerjisine yüksek kısmını
beyin aşık olmak gibi fa sitelerde
kullanır ya kriptopara da biraz öyle O
yüzden insanların o kadar heyecanlandı
görüyorsunuz Bir başka mesele iyi
hissetme durumu saten bu dünyanın insanı
iyi hissetmiyor hız karmaşa İzafiyet her
şey darmadağın olmuş durumda Yani bugün
değerler dediğimiz şey sadakat ile
kendinden vazgeçmiş bir ikrar halini
almış durumda dolayısıyla böyle bir
ortamda iyi hissetmek için araçlara
ihtiyacım var
Ama bu hissetme araçları bazen kazanmak
bazen kaybettikten sonra kazanmak ama
her defasında Kendini yeniden inşa
ettiğim bir durum zaten birde bu genel
mutsuzluk etkisiyle birleştiğinde bakın
Kripto paranın alın davranışının
arkasında iyi hissetme durumu da var ama
mutsuz hissetme durumu da var zaten
küresel bir affluenza yaşıyoruz öyle
ifade edildi genel mutsuzluk durumu
dünyada tarihte olmayacak kadar olmadığı
kadar
antidepresanların kullanım oranının
arttığını görüyoruz Amerika'da
antidepresanları bölgenin yakındaki
nehirlerin içerisindeki idrar
örneklerinden alarak ölçüyorlar 2020
yılında salgın öncesinde tarihin en
yüksek noktasına vardı Türkiye'de
yaklaşık yanlış hatırlamıyorsam 18000000
kutu antidepresan içildi alırsınız
antidepresan ilacı o kadar Sürükleyici
bir şey ki bu mutlu olduğunda da
ticaretini yapıyorsun mutsuz olduğunda
ticareti Ne yapıyorsun dolayı senin o
veyahut gibi yani asla çıkış yok evet
bu belirlenmesi Can sıkıntısı meşgule
niye Kripto para yatırma yapıyorsun
Çünkü yapabiliyorum bu kadar başka bir
şey sebep yok Her birimiz bir deneyim
yolculuğundaki biz achelois bir şey yani
hazır peşinde koşuyoruz onu Everest
Dağı'nın tepesinde olsa oraya tırmanarak
buluyoruz nerede bulmamız gerekiyorsa
orada buluyoruz Ama bu da çok eğlenceli
bir şey Elimde önde iki tane grafik al
saat kazandın kaybettim falan bu zaten
hayatın tümünü bir oyun formasyonuna
dönüştürmek gibi adeta bir gemi Fashion
oyunlaştırma meselesi gibi dönüyor bip
toplamda şunu söylemek mümkün
insanın zaten gerçekten çok zorlu
zamanları yaşadığı ve tarihin börek
mercimekli zamanın en hızlandı on yılına
girdik bir on yıl Daha geçireceğiz
zamanın daha da hızlandı göreceğiz
zamanın maliyeti çok artacak ve iyice
zorlandığımız görecek şunu söylemek
mümkün Türkiye örneklemini onu
söyleyeceğim Bakın ek bu durum
sosyopolitik durum ekonomi politik durum
aklınıza ne geliyorsa İnsanların ruh
durumu vesaire baktığımızda Aslında
biraz zor zamanlar yaşıyoruz ülke olarak
işte etrafımızdaki savaşları falan bütün
içsel siyaset tartışmaları bir kenara
bırakıyorum belki de bir daire sahibi
olmayı hayal eden son jenerasyon bizlik
çok net söylüyorum
Bu çok üzücü bir şey söylüyorum 31 daire
sahibi olmaya hayal edecek son cenaze
sustu
15 yıl sonra bu iş böyle devam ederse bu
kur artışları vergiler bilmem ne falan
Belki de Araba sahibi olmayı da hayal
edecek son jenerasyon biz olacağız
arabaya bakıyorum düz 386 bin liradan
başlıyor daha iki yıl önce aynı arabalar
60 bin liraydı gelir asla aynı düzeyde
yükselmemi Şimdi şunu söylemek mümkün bu
vakayı yaşayan insanların değil
kriptopara
aklınıza ne geliyorsa onun ticaretini
yapması son derece makul görünüyor Bu
kadar umutsuzluğun içerisinde insanların
tutunacak bir dal aradı bir formasyon
haline geldi kriptopara ama gelecek
burada değil gelecek ilk onu sordum ya
acaba bu üç ülke kendimizi Zul gördüğüm
için Nijerya Vietnam ve Filipinler'in
arasına sokmak istemedim Biz orada
değiliz
olmamalıyız bizim teknoloji üreten
geleceği Kur'an dereceye Entegre olan bu
on numara gençlerimize bize daire cep
gençlerimiz Falan diyoruz böyle ayırt
ediyoruz Bizim hayatımız var falan yani
hala yaşamaya devam ediyoruz biz umudu
aşılayacak kadar teknolojik kullanma ve
üretme becerisine sahip olmamız lazım ki
Ancak geleceğe bir şekilde Elimizi
uzatalım ve oraya varabilirim Diğer
türlü başka bir yolu görünmüyor var
Dolayısıyla kriptopara her zaman Kripto
paradan daha fazla bir şey daha maddeler
artırılabilir sürem yedincisi ifade
etmeye çalıştım İnşallah açıklayıcı
olmuştur Çok teşekkürler